good evening i'd like to provide the
american people with an update on our
efforts
to protect the integrity of a very
important 2020 election
if you count the legal votes i easily
win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to
steal the election from us if you count
the votes that came in late
we're looking at them very strongly but
a lot of votes came in late
i've already decisively won many
critical states including massive
victories in florida
iowa indiana ohio to name just a few we
won
these and many other victories despite
historic
election interference from big media big
money and big tech
as everybody saw we won by historic
numbers
and the pollsters got it knowingly wrong
they got it knowingly wrong
we had polls that were so ridiculous and
everybody knew it at the time there was
no blue wave that they predicted
they thought there was going to be a big
blue wave that was false that was done
for
suppression reasons but instead there
was a big
red wave and it's been properly
acknowledged actually by the media they
were
i think very impressed but that was
after the fact that doesn't do us any
good
we kept the senate despite having twice
as many seats to defend as democrats
and in a really uh much more
competitive states we've uh we did a
fantastic job with the senate i think
we're very proud of what's
happened there with many more seats to
defend they spent almost
200 million dollars on senate races in
south carolina and kentucky alone
two races and hundreds of millions of
dollars
overall against us at the national level
our opponents major donors were
wall street bankers and special
interests our major donors were police
officers farmers everyday citizens
yet for the first time ever we lost zero
races in the house
i was talking to kevin mccarthy today he
said he couldn't believe it
zero races very unusual thing zero and
actually won many new seats
with i think many more on the way this
was
also the year of the republican woman
more republican women were elected to
congress than
ever before that's a great achievement i
won the largest year of non-white voters
of any republican in 60 years including
historic
numbers of latino african-american
asian-american and native american
voters
the largest ever in our history
we grew our party by 4 million voters
the greatest turnout
in republican party history
democrats are the party of the big
donors the big media the big tech
it seems and republicans have become the
party of the american worker and that's
what's happened
and we're also i believe the party of
inclusion
as everyone now recognizes media polling
was
election interference in the truest
sense of that word
by powerful special interests these
really phony polls i have to call them
phony polls fake polls were designed to
keep our voters
at home create the illusion of momentum
for mr biden and diminish republicans
ability to raise
funds they were what's called
suppression polls everyone knows that
now
and uh it's never been used to the
extent that it's been used on this last
election
to highlight just a few examples the day
before election
quinnipiac which was wrong on
every occasion that i know had joe biden
up by five points in florida
and they were off by 8.4 points
and i won florida easily easily
so they had me
losing florida by a lot and i ended up
winning florida by a lot
other than that they were very accurate
they had
him up four points in ohio and they were
off by 12.2 points
and they also won ohio great state of
ohio very easily
the washington post had buyed up 17
points in wisconsin
and it was basically even they were off
by about 17 points
and they knew that they're not stupid
people they knew that
suppression there are now only a few
states yet to be
decided in the presidential race the
voting
apparatus of those states are run in all
cases by democrats
we were winning in all the key locations
by a lot actually
and then our numbers started
miraculously getting whittled away
in secret and they wouldn't allow
legally permissible observers we went to
court
in a couple of instances and we were
able to get the observers put in and
when the observers got there they wanted
them
60 70 feet away 80 feet 100 feet away or
outside the building to observe
people inside the building and we won a
case a big case and we have others
happening
a lot of lots of litigation even beyond
error litigation there's tremendous
amount of litigation generally because
of how unfair this process was and i
predicted that i've been talking about
mail-in voting for a long time it's
it's really destroyed our system it's a
corrupt system
and it makes people corrupt even if they
aren't by nature
but they become corrupt it's too easy
they want to find out how many the votes
they need and then they seem to be able
to find them
they wait and wait and then they find
them and
you see that on election night we were
ahead in vote
in north carolina by a lot tremendous
number of votes
and we're still ahead by a lot but uh
not as many because they're finding
ballots all of a sudden oh we have some
male in ballots it's amazing how those
maryland ballots are so one-sided too i
know that
it's supposed to be to the advantage of
the democrats but in all cases they're
so one-sided
we were up by nearly 700 000 votes in
pennsylvania i won pennsylvania by a lot
and that gets whittled down to i think
they said now we're up by 90 000 votes
and they'll keep coming and coming and
coming they find them all over
and they don't want us to have any
observers although we want a court case
the judge said you have to have
observers likewise endure
and they're appealing actually they're
appealing
we want a case that we want people to
watch and we want observers
and they're actually appealing which is
sort of interesting i wonder why that
appeal
that all we want to do is have people
watch as they do
the vote tabulations likewise in georgia
i won by a lot
a lot with a lead of over
getting close to 300 000 votes on
election night
in georgia and by the way got whittled
down
and now it's getting to be to a point
where i'll go from winning by a lot
to perhaps being even down a little bit
in georgia pipe burst in a far-away
location totally unrelated
to the location of what was happening
and they stopped counting
for four hours and a lot of things
happened
the election apparatus in georgia is run
by democrats we
also had margins of 300 000 and
michigan were way up in michigan won the
state
and in wisconsin we did likewise
fantastically well and
that got whittled down every in every
case they got whittled down
today we're on track to win arizona we
only need to carry
i guess 55 percent of the remaining vote
55
percent margins and
that's a margin that we've significantly
exceeded so we'll see what happens with
that but we're on track to do okay in
arizona
our goal is to defend the integrity of
the election will not allow
the corruption to steal such an
important election or any election for
that matter
and we can't allow silence anybody to
silence our voters
and manufacture results i've never had
i've been doing
a lot of public things for a long time
i've never had anything that's been as
inspirational by people calling talking
sending things to us i've never
seen such uh such love and such
affection and such
uh spirit as i've seen for this people
know what's happening and they see
what's happening and it's before their
eyes
and there are many instances which will
be reported very shortly
there's tremendous litigation going on
and this is a case where they're trying
to steal an election
they're trying to rig an election and we
can't let that happen detroit and
philadelphia known as two of the most
corrupt political places anywhere in our
country
easily cannot be responsible for
engineering the outcome of a
presidential race a very important
presidential race in pennsylvania
democrats have gone
to the state supreme court to try and
ban our election observers
and very strongly now we won the case
but they're they're going forward they
don't want anybody in there they don't
want anybody watching them as they
uh count the ballots and
i can't imagine why there's absolutely
no legitimate reason
why they would not want to have people
watching this process because if it's
straight
they would be they should be proud of it
instead they're
trying obviously to commit fraud
there's no question about that in
philadelphia observers have been
kept far away very far away so far
that people are using binoculars to try
and see and there's been
tremendous problems caused they put
paper on all of the windows so you can't
see in and the people
that are banned are very unhappy and
become somewhat violent
the 11th circuit ruled that in georgia
the votes have been
in by election day that they should be
in by election day
and they weren't votes are coming in
after election day
and they had a ruling already that you
have to have the votes in by election
day to the best of my knowledge votes
should be in by election day
and they didn't do that democrat
officials never believed they could win
this election honestly i really believe
that
that's why they did the mail-in ballots
where there's tremendous
corruption and fraud going on that's why
they
mailed out tens of millions of
unsolicited ballots without any
verification measures whatsoever
and i've told everybody that these
things would happen
because i've seen it happen i watched a
lot of different elections
before they decided to go with this big
massive
election with tens of millions of
ballots going out to
everybody in many cases totally
unsolicited
this was unprecedented in american
history this was by design despite years
of
claiming to care about the election
security
they refuse to include any requirement
to verify signatures
identities or even determine whether
they're eligible or
ineligible to vote people are walking in
there they have no idea
they're just taking the numbers they're
writing down things the workers and
doing a lot of bad things and we have a
lot of information coming and litigation
that you'll see that will
shake even your people up and you've
seen it all the officials overseeing
the counting in pennsylvania and other
key states are all part of a
corrupt democrat machine that you've
written about and for a long time you've
been writing about
the corrupt democrat machine i went to
school there and i know a lot about it
hasn't changed a long time ago and
hasn't changed it's gotten worse in
pennsylvania partisan democrats have
allowed ballots in the state to be
received three days after the election
and we think much more than that and
they are counting those
without even postmarks or any
identification
whatsoever so you don't have postmarks
you don't have identification
there have been a number of disturbing
irregularities
across the nation our campaign has been
denied access to observe
any counting in detroit detroit is
another place
and i wouldn't say has the best
reputation for
election integrity poll workers in
michigan were duplicating ballots
but when our observers attempted to
challenge the activity those poll
workers
jumped in front of the volunteers to
block their views so that they couldn't
see what they were doing
and it became a little bit dangerous
one major hub for counting ballots and
detroit covered up the windows again
with large pieces of cardboard and
so they wanted to protect and block the
counting area they didn't want anybody
seeing the county even though these were
observers who were
legal observers that were supposed to be
there in detroit there were hours of
unexplained delay in delivering many of
the votes for counting
the final batch did not arrive until
four in the morning
and uh even though the polls closed at
eight o'clock so they brought it in
and the batches came in and nobody knew
where they came from
we've also been denied access to observe
in
critical places in georgia and multiple
swing states counting
was halted for hours and hours on
election night
with results withheld from major
democrat-run locations only to appear
later and they certainly appeared and
they all had the name biden on them or
just about all i think
almost all they all had the name biden
on them
which is a little strange i challenge
joe and every democrat to
clarify that they only want legal votes
because they talk about votes and i
think they should use the word legal
legal votes
we want every legal vote counted and i
want every legal vote counted we want
openness and transparency
no secret count rooms no mystery ballots
no
illegal votes being cast after election
day
you have election day and the laws are
very strong on that you have an election
day
and they don't want votes cast after
election day and they want the process
to be an honest one it's so important
we want an honest election we want an
honest count
and we want honest people working back
there because it's a very important job
so
that's the way this country is going to
win that's the way the united states
will win
and we think we will win the election
very easily we think there's going to be
a lot of litigation because we have so
much evidence so much proof
and it's going to end up perhaps at the
highest court in the land
we'll see but we think there'll be a lot
of litigation because we can't have
an election stolen by like this and i i
tell you i would
i have been talking about this for many
months with all of you
and i've said very strongly that mail-in
ballots are going to end up being a
disaster
small elections were a disaster smaller
easy to handle elections
were disastrous this is a large-scale
version and it's getting worse and worse
every day we're hearing
stories that are horror stories absolute
horror stories
and we can't let that happen to the
united states of america it's not a
question of who wins
republican democrat joe myself
we can't let that happen to our country
we can't be disgraced by having
something like this happen
so it will be hopefully cleared up maybe
soon i hope soon
but it'll probably go through a process
a legal process
and as you know i've claimed certain
states and
he's claiming states so we can both
claim the states but ultimately i have a
feeling judges are going to have to rule
but there's been a lot of shenanigans
and we can't stand for that in our
country
thank you very much